Jayda takes three hours to deliver 189
newspapers on her paper route what is
the rate per hour the rate per hour
which she delivers the newspaper so this
first sentence tells us that she
delivers or she takes three hours three
hours to deliver to deliver 189
newspapers so you have three hours for
every 189 newspapers newspapers that's
what the first sentence told us but we
want to figure out the rate per hour or
the newspapers per hour so we can really
just flip this rate right here so if we
were to just flip it we would have 189
newspapers newspapers for every for
every three hours for every three hours
which is really the same information
we're just flipping what's in the
numerator and what's in the denominator
now we want to write it in as simple as
possible form and let's see if this top
number is divisible by 3 1 plus 8 is 9
plus 9 is 18 so that is divisible by 3
so let's divide this numerator and this
denominator by 3 to simplify things so
if you divide 189 by 3 let's do it over
the side over on the side right here 3
goes into 189 3 goes into 18 6 times 6
times 3 is 18
subtract bring down the 9 18 minus 18
was nothing 3 goes into 9 exactly 3
times 3 times 3 is 9 no remainder so if
you divide 189 by 3 you get 63 and if
you divide 3 by 3 you're going to get 1
you have to divide both the numerator
and the denominator by the same number
so now we have 63 newspapers for every
one hour or we can write this as 63 over
1 newspapers per hour so we could write
this as 63 over 1 news papers per hour
for one hour or we can write this as 63
because 63 over 1 is the same thing as
6363
newspapers newspapers per hour